[Musique]
bon j'en tire on voit isabelle alors
aujourd'hui tu va nous raconter ta
petite astuce ton truc réussir le gigot
pouvait le gigot il ya un petit truc
qu'on va expliquer fini les tabous
d'avoir peur de mal cuir le gigot et
après il ya un petit truc pour lie aussi
que nous expliquera en même temps ça
c'est vraiment un plat du dimanche cela
bon pilote gigot c'est un mets préférés
plein repas de rois à voilà alors tu vas
nous expliquer ce qu'il faut comme
ingrédient ah bah voilà on va commencer
tout de suite eh bien il me faudrait un
gigot alors abu gigot d'agneau il faudra
50 g de beurre
2 destinée de ville du sel du poivre de
la i3 tête des haricots blancs du thym
du laurier du creux sont une à deux
bottes selon ce qu'on veut si on aime
bien la verdure comme henri iv croatie
pour la décoration du persil et nous
faudra deux décidé de les poursuivre
notre note rails pour pocher not try
dans le lait ça c'est vraiment un truc
voilà c'est le petit truc et ben voilà
on va attaquer
alors commencer par cuir le gigot donc
on va commencer par le saisir et on va
le saisir et le coloré le mettre à four
très chaud pendant un quart d'heure
vingt minutes pour le cas une petite
carapace et qui est déjà si tu veux
qu'ils qui cuit qui est saisie donc le
sang va pas bouger et le gigot donc
pendant 80 minutes des quais puis je
leur jeu le tir et on le met sur le côté
on s'en occupe plus
alors je met du beurre à peu près ça
comme grave
ville et de l'huile
alors isabelle notre gigot balle piquée
d'ail non j'ai déjà coupé un petit peu 4
gousses d'ail
alors je vais le sic et isabelle dans le
jarret si tu veux
dans la souris exactement ses meilleurs
morceaux d'avion alors exactement
pourquoi parce que le sang va circuler
et si je pique dans ma souris et là il
va circuler aussi la voix la
regarde mon beurre et bien chaud et je
vais commencer à saisir pour jégo
voilà j'ai tous les côtés d'abord ils
arrêtent un côté peau toujours pas le
côté peau donc à la grèce
voilà je vais donc autour des monges
hugo
loi ils commencent déjà à colorer pour
bien le coloré de tous les côtés mais
pour éviter de cliquer pour justement de
les garder le stand ça soit un peu je
vais mettre du sel
moi j'aime mieux la salière
saupoudrez bien de celle copieusement
donc je ne vais pas piqué
et j'avais bien le poivre est
alors il n'a pas elle a vu plonger
gaulle et bien des os et j'ai garé l'os
du milieu et il manque les eaux de la
seine comment boucher a désossé donc tu
vas demander qui tu enlèves les eaux de
la seine c'est ça on va les mettre sous
la selle je peux pas dire s'il tue mais
celle du gigot
et je vais mettre mes os maison ça c'est
aussi un petit truc ouais les eaux c'est
à dire tout à l'heure au moment des
glaces trompe pas reposer sur les os
pour corte le gigot ikram dans le jeu et
on va le mettre à cuire
pendant à peu près 20 minutes
le plus gros djigo tracasseries on va le
mettre pendant 20 minutes au four
valérie serres l'après-midi alors ça
l'idéal dans l'idéal si on ne fait pas
ça dépend ce qu'on fait l'idéal c'est de
le faire une heure avant le repas
isabelle on va s'occuper de nos haricots
mairie qu on trempait
pendant toute la nuit ou 5 6 heures ils
ont trempé dont tu vois ils sont bien
gonflés gatti sont beaux ils sont bien
gonflés je vais changer l'eau mais ricco
parce que si on laisse qu'un mémo des
fois il ya une fermentation qui arrive
donc faut mieux la changer je vais
changer d'os je vais me préparer du thym
du laurier tu me prépares ça une branche
de thym branches de laurier
c'est du frais en plus
voilà
là il n'a peut-être beaucoup alors on
arrête une branche et de trois feuilles
de laurier et je mette un peu de sel
on va les mettre à cuire à peu près
pendant une heure une heure et demie ça
dépend la ricoh vous travaux qui vont à
peu près tenir pendant une heure une
heure et demie mais isabelle on va
s'occuper de notre à y regarde bien je
vais m oui mais du lait à peu près de
deux décennies de ramequins et une en
plongée mon âme regarde bien voilà tu
peux en mettre 3 4 gousses et on va le
mettre à pau chez tranquillement pour
qu'ils aillent cuisent dans le lait et
pourquoi lui dans les limbes injustement
pour qu'il garde son petit goût est le
canton le mettra avec le jus stable un
petit bout qu'on trouve pas dieu via ce
les styles qui verra ses formidables
dans le goût du gigot commettront
d'assaut ce dernier moment et c'est ça
le petit truc c'est un peu du confit
d'ail c'est délicieux et ben voilà on va
laisser mijoter tout ça va faire
bouillir et et que ça vous réduire à
il ya 20 minutes
je mangeais 28 bien saisi c'est normal
que ça fasse que ça plus barbant mais
bon je regarde si les boas oui et là tu
laisses sur le côté alors là on s'en
occupe ah ça c'est l'enfant abandonné
il est là il est saisi on virait quel
crime et y ai pas cuit à l'intérieur est
archi saignant et maintenant il va
reposer on pense qu'une gigot détente et
belle isabelle pendant que tu me fais
mon ancre son avec amour je vais
remettre mon gigot à cuire regarde voilà
dans un four bien bien chaud et là on va
leur mettre à cuire là il ya une heure
qui se repose à peu près on va le mettre
à cuire à 15h20 et ce sera fait qu'à
pour nous inviter ou nous même si on n'a
pas la voilà donc pendant qu'ils lui gbf
haricots l'asa ci sont beaux
ils sont cuits sont tus faut ajouter un
pôle soit un petit peu mais c'est normal
et j'aimais
mon haye
qui est en train de pêcher
tranquillement qu'on va bientôt mettre
dans le jeu la sauce du gigot dix
minutes avant qu'ils aient fini de cuir
pour que la langue ça prenne du boudigau
tu as à faire une la gousse d'ail qu'on
va goûter c'est savoureux que le givre
alors isabelle
mont rigaud regarde
y'a comme cuit il manque un peu près 5
diminue
et je vais simplement plongé
et ça tu vas y ça va avoir un petit goût
délicieux
monde ayaka soupçonne les mêmes c'est
pas grave
j'ai mon âge
je retire pour patrick rave
et j'ai mon oeil les gousses d'ail qui
vont tenir dans la sauce qui vont finir
de cuire la sauce tac la fin de cuisson
du gigot et je leur mette à cuire 5
minutes
tu fermes le faut
bonjour voila
l remis à cuire 5 10 minutes et on va
voir des glaces inc gigot sera presque
prêt mais erik cole le creux sont assez
bons
mais isabelle on va des glaces et
d'autres gigot
asseyez-vous un genre comme on dit
voilà
alors
duel enlevé le retirer deux minutes là
je peux expliquer basque et cuirassiers
bout on va enlever
l'excédent de graisse
dans une casserole
et maintenant on va laisser caraméliser
un peu après 6h et de louis et ça dégage
des glaciers
y en aura pour tous retrouvé dans le
rhin pour tout le monde bon évidemment
nous recommander à deux on a mis 8 10 12
d'agde si vous aimez bien là et points
mais une trentaine ça dépend le 1
maintenant c'est le moment mais trop pro
ça va sauter à leur niveau attention
voilà donc tous les sucres
gallas est ce que mal devient
et on va finir de crime gigot et elle
regarde bien le petit truc on va pousser
m jégo sur les os pourquoi qui trempe
dans la sauce pour toi qui voudraient
sinon liera les deux modes regarde mal
laisser au dessus pour pas quitteront
voilà
heureux mais nôtres gigot effet ils
restent plus 3 4 minutes voilà
et on peut découper notre gigot dans
trois quatre minutes et c'est ce qu'on
va s'occuper a fait a préparé deux
assiettes
et ci est beau
voilà
dans ceux qui voient la main ça c'est
fait mongi goyer beau regard bien alors
je crois qu'il va t'il qu une fois de
plus
à ça va bien les eaux sont partis là
alors on a bien enlevé c'est bien de le
dire on a bien levé l'os de la selle
donc ça va bien découpé quand il est
beau allez tu vas porter les assiettes
alors on va mettre un petit morceau
une belle tranche de rose et vert ça
s'il est beau la deuxième
bonaiuti a pu darricau alors un petit
peu laico
ya les égoutter quand même eh ben c'est
ça c'est le judo à rigaud tout
simplement avec des ricoh des lingots
comme ça semble dole à paris on dit pas
ça mais voilà alors on va mettre regarde
un peu importe l'assiette un peu d'ail
voilà il confié avec ma sauce les thugs
outrance taille
bien plus de persil voilà alors est là
bas
voilà un petit pas de faire side
quartier beaumont gigot quand même et tu
vois alors évidemment quand on découpe
on le laisse simplement regarde dans son
plat
au chaud évidemment pour les inviter au
bord du faux mais regarde s'il est beau
il a vraiment une coupe terrible il est
vraiment chouette mais la belle on y
voit
par là avec tellement beau
la cochlée on n'oublie jamais c'est pas
gigot qui attend les inviterait ses
invités qui attendent des jumeaux
jégo celle m eh ben isabelle goûtez-moi
ça
un peu en 2011
[Musique]